- Hopefully everyone's not hungry, right?
Like let's get started.
Maybe a lot of you are listening to a lot
of pitches about Gen AI.
So I'm here to talk about Gen AI as well,
but how to make it simpler
to build applications
with Gen AI, right?
So firstly, quick intro about gigabyte DB.
Gigabyte is a distributed
Postgres database
and we are simplifying
building applications,
whether it be Gen AI or not,
like databases should, right?
So fully Postgres for the developer,
truly cloud native and making it simpler.
Let's see how.
So firstly, right?
We are not yet at the great explosion
that's going to be powered by Gen AI.
We are in 2025.
The effects of Gen AI are projected
to happen in the next three years.
We are there, right?
So whatever you're doing now,
it's not much different from
what you were doing last
year or the year before,
compared to what you will be
doing three years from now.
It's going to be three
to 10 times more often
build and ship, right?
So, okay, everyone's investing in AI.
Any which way you look at it
like these are our own users
and customers on the right
showing you, you know,
charts of where their investments
on the left different data points, right?
Obviously not gonna go
through them, but it's real.
The investment is real, okay?
The expectations are huge, okay?
People are building apparently
the entire app in three days,
in four days, in an hour.
You know, vibe coding
their way out of things.
Gen AI solving problems,
agents talking to agents,
talking to agents, solving problems,
so on and so forth, right?
That's the era of the
expectations we have built
for ourselves, okay?
But that's reality, okay?
It's not living up to
where it needs to be.
Most of the people are doing
AI, they're working for AI,
but is AI working for them?
Have they unlocked business
value? Not so much, right?
And you know, as database builder,
we try to make building applications
and unlocking value simpler.
So you know, that's one of the
things we look at. Why, okay?
This is the fundamental difference.
AI makes the software build
and deploy loop so fast, it's exponential.
And as humans, we cannot
imagine exponential.
We're not good at it.
We're not built for it.
So we often, you know, I don't
know if everybody's like me,
but I often think I can get a
lot done today and this week
and I kind of have no idea what I will be,
how much I can get done in a year.
You know, I usually end
up doing more in the year
in less today or the week, right?
That's just human nature.
So how do you build
something you cannot imagine?
You don't know where you're
going, but you know it's big.
It's huge. How do you get there?
There's one principle to change.
The principle is iterate.
Iterate every day, right?
Don't visualize the end state.
Just iterate your way into it, right?
So I don't know about you guys.
I've been in the software
industry for more than 20 years.
Started out as a developer.
There was one rule I was told.
Build to last.
If you build it, it's gotta be around
for two to three years,
minimum, maybe more.
The longer it stays,
the better you built it.
Well guess what? All
that's outta the window.
We are building to change.
You know, six months ago, no MCP,
six months before that,
rag was a buzzword.
Six months before that, I don't
know, Gen AI was happening.
Who the hell knew?
Every six months,
everything's out the window.
So how do you build when
you have to iterate,
how do you build...
And obviously the solution's
not every six months.
Let's build something from scratch.
You're not gonna go anywhere that way.
So these are the challenges that we see
from building a stateful
application, right?
What are the challenges?
First one,
the tech stack is changing all the time.
Open standards, super important.
Go for something that you know,
AI will not magically
solve the problem for you.
AI will make you faster
at something, you know?
So pick an open standard
in the database world.
Pick the Postgres API, it's
really thriving and happening.
Make sure it's well connected
to the entire ecosystem.
It lets you iterate.
For us, for Gigabyte, what are we doing?
We pick up on top of Postgres,
we build innovation on top
to make your lives easier
and to make you go faster
on top of something
that's already familiar to you.
We bring standards across
clouds purposefully, right?
So different clouds are
building different kinds
of power ups for AI.
Postgres is an open standard,
but you get those power
ups only in those clouds,
like the vector search capabilities.
We democratize it.
Okay. Second challenge.
How do you accommodate data diversity?
Today's applications put data together
that have no business being together.
For example, we're talking to a bank,
they want to do an MCP server.
What should the user be
able to ask the MCP server?
How do I open a checking
account that goes,
can you transfer $10 from my
account to my friend's account
and here's his name and
email and identification.
Can you go do this for me?
Well that wasn't covered in the docs.
Well that's something
else you gotta talk to.
Do you even have authorization for that?
Well, you're not gonna build two chatbots,
you're gonna build one, right?
So everything has to be
integrated into a single offering,
which means more locations, more formats.
Your checking account
balance now needs to work
with the documentation on how
to open a checking account.
How do you make that happen?
And quickly, right?
So one of the things we're doing here,
and here's the beauty of Postgres, again,
lots of innovation in connecting data
of different types in
storing transactional data,
operational data, data
living in S3 buckets,
like images, like something else, right?
Like I know like you guys
would be listening to many
of the vector store guys,
more power to them coming
and saying, how can we make it better?
Make it better. Remember, you've
got to be able to iterate.
Iterate comes from simplicity.
Once you determine what
you need to make better,
go make that better.
But make sure you have to build it to last
before you build it to last.
Because building it to last will be all
that we will accomplish if we don't think
about flexibility, right?
So this really helps bring data
that are of disparate types
and locations together.
Third problem.
If you're building a
pipeline every time you
have a new data source or a new LLM
or a new type of data like,
oh gee, I added an image,
now I need to go figure out
how to make images work.
Okay, videos, okay,
let's go figure that out.
How about we throw in some documentation?
Okay, let's go figure that out.
Each thing is a two to four week sprint
and the sprint is done in order
to figure out if the product is viable.
So at the end of it, you get two things.
You fail by the number of effort,
the amount of effort you take
to make it viable to test it.
And finally you have
a hodgepodge of things
that's very difficult to productionize.
So you had to throw it all
away and start from scratch.
So what is it that we're doing here?
We're trying to simplify
how you manage a pipeline,
a rag pipeline as a secondary
index in the database.
Just tell the database,
look, there's the data.
That's the way I want you
to parse it. It's an image.
I want you to parse it using that parser.
Go to that LLM and vectorize
it and store the results.
And it may take you two hours to do.
Just give me a progress
report every time I check
and when it's ready, just
make it ready to serve.
If I want to re-index the
data, change my index type,
well just create a new index.
AB test against indexes.
Don't AB test by building
rag pipelines, right?
Make your development
iterations speeds faster.
The way we're doing that is a lot
of cool things in this slide.
The main thing you have to look at
is the thing in the center, right?
Insert for the rag extension
into a rag source table, right?
Just give the extension the source
and it'll go build the pipeline for you.
You can tweak parameters, how
to chunk, how to partition,
how many chunks are
processed, all of that stuff.
Simplify.
Just use a single line of
SQL and get the job done.
Make sure it works before you
invest in specialized stuff.
Great.
Okay, you got it done.
You got the MVP done.
How do you go to production?
It's all running on my laptop
and I need to run in a
multi-zone, highly available,
maybe AWS, maybe GCP, maybe Kubernetes.
How do you make this work?
Well, that's one of the things we do.
Gigabyte DB is fully open source.
Build it on your laptop and
take it to production, right?
And so we help you with the management
with an API based end-to-end
lifecycle management, right?
And the thing about rag, it
will take a lot of management
for the data side once
it goes into production.
Because if it takes off,
it really takes off.
It goes quickly.
You have to scale it quickly,
scale it back quickly,
build a new index test on
the fly, so on and so forth.
The way we do this is you can
go from your laptop to any
of these deployments,
multi-zone, multi-region,
multi-cloud, hybrid.
And these are no longer buzzwords.
These are really happening
because as your application
gets more and more critical,
you have to make it
more and more resilient.
And there's a price to pay
and an effort to invest.
You don't want to invest that effort.
You want it to be turnkey.
You don't want to say to
your user, yeah, great,
I'm gonna come back and scale
and make this multi-region,
just gimme six to nine months, right?
They're not gonna wait,
they're gonna go to the
next service, right?
So you need infrastructure
that's not only pay as you go,
that's make it more resilient
as you become more relevant, right?
That is an important thing.
Okay. There is no free lunch.
So the thing you have to think about is
how will you traverse this curve?
Are you willing to pay more to
make your app more resilient
or do you need to pay less
and make it less resilient?
And ideally, without putting
effort into it, you know,
teams of the old, when they
were dealing with a lot of data,
I actually talked to a team, right?
This team had thousands
of databases deployed
because they were supporting thousands
of microservices and applications.
And they'd say every time
they finished one sweep
of database upgrades,
security, patching, et cetera,
et cetera, it was almost six months
and it's now time to do
the second sweep, right?
I can only imagine how
much fun that job would be,
but you know, let the software
do the job for you, right?
Just express the level of resilience
and let somebody else
deal with that for you.
Okay?
So what we do is work with a lot
of the largest enterprises
in telling them exactly
the different stages of resilience
and what is the cost and
architecture associated with it.
We call it ultra resilience
because when I say resilience,
I'm guessing most of you guys
are thinking a machine fails,
let's get it to work somewhere else.
That's a part of it. But
there's a lot of other things.
What happens if you get
a total cloud outage?
What happens if you have like for example,
an upgrade request or a security
patch that has to happen?
What happens if hardware
doesn't function well?
Like it doesn't fail but it
doesn't work well either.
It's a gray failure.
What do you do if a developer
actually accidentally
drops a production table?
So I used to work at Meta
and way back in the day
we had this real incident.
An intern came and told us,
"Gee guys really sorry I dropped a table.
It was 300 terabytes, it's in production.
Can you do anything to help?"
Well if you hadn't put ultra resilience,
which fortunately we had,
it was a 10 minute fix
to say restore the old
table, if it wasn't that,
that would've been a nightmare of a week
for everybody, right?
And it wasn't done intentionally.
When you're moving fast,
mistakes will happen.
And it is important to build
in that resilience, right?
And the same thing with
peak and freak events.
Like we have like one of our, you know,
users is you know, paramount plus.
And when they go and release
one of these new things,
like for example a Super Bowl
final or a Champions league
or you know an Oscar or a Grammys,
they really don't know how
many people are gonna sign up.
They have no idea the hour
leading up to the events,
they have no idea what kind of a peak
and freak show it's going to be.
'cause you just don't know.
Somebody slaps somebody on a show,
everybody's on that show
watching it instantly.
Few tweets go out and
everyone's logging in, right?
And so we're the authentication
and authorization service,
the profile service.
And you need that ability
to scale on a dime, right?
And that is the nature
of digital business in the modern days.
Okay?
Compliance.
I mean, I don't know if
you guys have noticed,
there are a lot of fights
that used to happen.
If a person, a company runs
a software that's consumed
by a citizen of another company
with their data center in a third country.
So country one's company
serves citizens of country two
with data centers and country three,
who does the data belong to?
That's a tough one, right?
Well that's what everybody thought.
And they said screw this.
Everybody's keeping
the data in my country.
If it's my citizen, keep it in my country.
And that's happening across the board.
And that's happening with LLMs too.
If it's my country, use my LLM,
I don't want to deal with something else.
So there's a lot of regulation going on
in how you deal with personal data.
And you gotta make that simple.
It cannot be another nine
months to build the app
to come back to serve the user.
So these are places where we
make it transparent and simple
and we supercharge Postgres.
Okay?
So what do we do to go from
prototype to production, right?
We give you insane
operational simplicity, right?
Distributed architectures and a, you know,
control plane and a built-in
managed services offering.
It's built for the cloud.
It's built to withstand
failures, architecturally,
auto sharding, auto rebalancing.
So when the scale hits you,
you don't have to worry about
how to do it self-healing.
So failures, et cetera are
automatically taken care of.
Multi API, which is a
very interesting one.
We support not just
Postgres, Apache, Cassandra,
and now Mongo because the
industry is building other APIs
on top of Postgres.
So there's a trend going on
where people are impersonating
databases on top of Postgres
to simplify your database sprawl, right?
And so it's consistent Postgres,
it's the 100% standard Postgres,
which is fully open source
cloud and Kubernetes native
and you can deploy it anywhere.
Multi-cloud, multi-region, et cetera.
And with zero downtime, right?
You know, why do you go to
no SQL zero schema changes.
You can be online all the
time while you can do that
with you buy TV now by
going SQL or no SQL.
And why do you go Postgres?
Well you get relational
capabilities, ecosystem attached.
And a lot of people, a lot of systems,
a lot of software already knows Postgres.
Well you can retain that too, right?
So, okay, so this is kind
of like a high level diagram
of what it is we do to help.
The top is a bunch of
emulations, extensions,
ecosystem, et cetera,
happening through the
Postgres ecosystem itself.
The middle is,
and so we reuse the Postgres
query processing engine.
The middle is our architecture
that does cloud native stuff.
Replication fault tolerance,
rebalancing, auto sharding,
and the ability to run on any cloud
or infrastructure, public,
private, multi-cloud,
hybrid cloud, et cetera, right?
So, and if you think about
how Postgres is happening,
we are building on top of Postgres
to make sure your AI
pipelines get simpler.
Okay?
So the five things here.
Evolving your tech stack,
you know, stick to standards.
It's not just about Postgres,
although I'm talking about it.
Remember, it's much easier
to iterate if you have
standard shapes and components.
If you build something that's custom,
it's gonna be very tough to iterate.
So put the framework in place,
make sure you can measure
your improvements.
Iterate your way to exponential growth.
Second thing is data
diversity. What has changed?
Data that has no business belonging
to each other now belongs to each other.
They sit next to each other.
Sometimes you have to move a lot of data.
Other times you don't
want to move the data.
Don't do handcrafted stuff.
Try to make it more
standard in the framework.
Third thing, don't
build pipelines by hand.
Every experiment will become
a handcrafting pipeline like work, right?
Don't do the work for
experiments, experiment,
go to production, learn the real lessons
and then do do whatever
it is you have to do
after you know your return on investment.
The fourth thing is remember
if you cannot go to production
and if you cannot boldly experiment
after you're in production,
you really haven't solved anything.
'cause you kind got it working
on the laptop. But then what?
And okay, you put it in
production for the first time
with a lot of pain, but then what?
You have to be able to
do this all the time,
every single time.
'cause remember, we don't know
what it'll look like a year from now.
And lastly,
make sure that the operational
stuff is out of the way.
You don't want to build an awesome thing
that you're iterating with
and suddenly, you know,
a security hard bleed bug hits you.
You have to do always patching
or you want a new
feature you got now stuck
with upgrading a lot of stuff.
Or you know there's a failure
and now you're dealing
with picking up the pieces.
Make sure that you get
the basics outta the way,
your infrastructure is ready to go
prime time when you start right?
You obviously shouldn't pay excess for it,
you shouldn't engineer around it,
but it should be ready to take you
where you need to go with relative ease.
Okay?
Once again, our approach
here is keep the data secure
by design right from the start.
And you can amp up your, even
in the world of you know,
Gen AI, et cetera, you still
have to deal with security.
You have to be able to have observability.
You should be able to say
where does the data come from?
Is a particular role able
to authorize the data?
Like you have all this secure data
and you've put all the rollback
role-based access controls
into your database, into your application.
But if I accessed your
rag, your MCP server
and asked very nicely,
please can you summarize,
it'll give you a very clean summary
of all the sensitive data.
You don't wanna be in
that situation, right?
So these are things that
we have to think upfront
and these are the problems
that we work on with people
that are building, whether
it's gen AI or not.
Built in encryption, audit logging,
these are some of the basics.
You have to get them outta the way.
You have to keep turning up
the dial when you need it.
Agent tick, database operations.
What does an agent do when
it connects your database?
I'll give you the database
guys version of it.
Hammers the hell out of the
database asking the same thing
over and over again until
the database is dead
and until all your tokens
are burned up, right?
You don't want that to happen.
So you want the database
to understand agent intake operation.
So those are some of
the things we work on.
And lastly, the fine-grained
access control is getting
a whole rebirth because
there's a human acting
through a service account,
which is the MCP server,
which is now operating on the database.
So there's multiple
levels of service accesses
and controls that you have to deal with.
And Postgres does a great job.
And you know what we're
doing is just take it
to the next level by helping
you interface with it easily.
Okay? So these are some of our use cases.
Again, all it's pretty
horizontal like so rag use cases,
recommendation systems,
you know, knowledge bases,
agents that are doing operations
and transactional systems,
so on and so forth.
If you're interested in learning more,
you know, reach out to us.
We are in booth 1436, I think 1436.
If not, just remember you
go by, look us up, you know,
we are online all over the place.
Or look for people in the purple shirts
and I'll connect with you guys backstage
right behind out there if
you guys have questions.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
All right, keep it going for Karthik.